well I'm ready to go I've eaten my papa
coupe wouldn't be ready this early if I
was just drinking liquid like some kind
of sucker
most days I will have two cups of coffee
a day the smell of coffee also makes me
feel better it's really more about the
ritual of drinking when the actual drink
itself I'm addicted to coffee but also I
love it so I don't really care that I'm
addicted to it so we're giving up coffee
for a whole week and trading it out for
chewable coffee it hurts me to say that
they did not look how I thought oh they
smell good though if you can see it's
just a very that's squishy this is just
camping oh man that flavor really
punches you in the mouth see - I'm sorry
I think knowing what to expect the taste
isn't as bad this time so well this week
might be all right you know they didn't
taste so bad this morning and I was
pretty okay so I'm optimistic about this
no they still taste better my room is
very cold this morning
conveniently there's a cube here on a
cold morning there's nothing more
reassuring and a nice way to start the
day than just a nice hot cup of coffee
but I didn't have that hmm I wanted a
cup of coffee and I'm seriously
regretting agreeing to do this I want to
do a coffee shop just now just to just
Stephanie just to smell it you know I
will openly admit to cheating I gave up
on the cubes I went straight for the
coffee
I'm just too tired Thank You coffee but
I needed to make it through today and I
wasn't gonna be able to do it I'm just
those cubes trying to watch The Morning
News here and normally I'd do this while
oh it was a bit of a roller coaster but
it was really just like the top of the
roller coaster to the bottom of the drop
I always talk about how great it'll be
when we can eat meals in pill form it's
like if you're like well I really like
Thanksgiving I'm gonna sit home this
year or any turkey flavored cotton candy
alone drinking coffee makes me happy and
I'm gonna keep doing it now I sound like
a cigarette smoker but I get that if
you're like super in a bind and you need
like a quick pick-me-up I guess that's
what these are for do I get a little
coffee the joy this brings me can never
be replaced by a damn sugar cube Coffee
is a gift don't fix what's not broken
you know I don't necessarily care for
the sweet stuff but it's still better
than those cubes anything's better than
those cubes
just eating a cube